well you've heard by now that mint is
closing and you and four million other
budgeters are going to be hung out to
dry come
January hey folks Dave Ramsey here the
CEO of Ramsey Solutions and Creator and
founder of the budgeting app every
dollar we've been helping millions of
people budget for over 30 years and we
want to help you right now download
every dollar for free today and get the
budgeting app that will not sell your
data shove credit cards down your throat
and it'll actually help you get out of
debt and become wealthy and that's what
we're doing anyway hey guys we're not
going anywhere this is what we do go to
everydollar.com and get two free months
of our premium version on me you can
build your first budget in less than 10
minutes with the best budgeting app
available